let's figure out how long this object is
going to be in the air given that its
vertical velocity or the magnitude of it
the vertical velocity is s sine of theta
so its speed in the vertical direction
is s
sine
of theta so how long is it going to be
in the air well if i told you that
something is going upwards at 10 meters
per second and gravity is decelerating
it at 10 meters per second squared so
every second it's going to slow it down
by 10 meters per second how long will it
take for that object to get to 0 to not
to stop moving let me write that down
let's say that some some object is
moving upwards at 10 meters per second
and let's say that gravity
let's say that gravity is slowing it
down
gravity
slowing it down slowing
it down
at
10 meters per second per second so every
second that goes by it'll slow this
thing down by 10 meters per second
well it'll take it exactly one second to
get make it go from 10 meters per second
to zero meters per second and then it's
going to be at some height in the air
and then things are going to start
accelerating gravity is going to start
accelerating it downward and then it'll
take another second for it to go from
zero from having no velocity to having
10 meters per second again so in this
case it'll take
the time in the air we could say time
sub air i guess is going to be equal to
this 10 meters per second your velocity
10 meters per second
divided by divided by the acceleration
divided by this 10 meters per second
10 meters per second per second times 2.
this is how long it will take for the
object to go from 10 meters per second
to zero at some point in the air and
then you're going to it's going to take
the exact same amount of time for it to
fall back to the ground so times two
so times two if the object was moving
upwards at 20 meters per second and
gravity is still slowing it down at 10
meters per second per second then it's
going to take 2 seconds so you would
have if this was 20 if that was 20 then
this would be 20 and it'll take 2
seconds to slow it down to 0 and then 2
more seconds until it hits the ground
again for it to speed back up as it
approaches the ground so no matter what
no matter what your upward velocity no
matter what your upward velocity the
time in the air the time in the air is
going to be your speed your vertical
speed
divided by the acceleration of gravity
and this is the amount of time it's
going to take you to go from this point
to that point to have some vertical
velocity and then slow down to zero and
it's going to take the exact same amount
of time for you to speed back up by
gravity and get to your original speed
we're assuming no air resistance so it's
kind of a pure problem so this is the
time up the time down is going to be the
same thing so we can multiply that by 2.
now we already know what the vertical
component for our problem is it is s
sine of theta so we can just substitute
that back in there and we know how long
we're going to be in the air the time in
the air is going to be our speed or i
should maybe put the 2 out front 2
times s sine theta s sine
theta and we make it clear this 2 right
here is this 2 right there
all of that over
the acceleration of gravity so if you
told me that i'm shooting this object
off at i don't know 100 meters per
second so if this is 100 meters per
second and if theta were i don't know
let's say theta were
30 degrees
then sine of theta would be one half so
it would be 100 meters per second times
one half divided by the acceleration of
gravity times two will tell you exactly
how long you would be in the air how
long it takes to go up all the way come
come to become stationary and then come
fall back down to the ground